wir kommen dann zum nächsten zuschauer
fall bettina schubert hat uns ein
handy-video geschickter schon rein
ich hatte anlässlich unserer goldenen
hochzeit eine kreuzfahrt im juli gebucht
diese wurde wie alle anderen reißen auch
abgesagt und ich habe auch meinen
reisepreis anstandslos zurück bekommen
nur die reiserücktrittsversicherung von
440 euro wurden behalten mit der
begründung
bei der hausratversicherung bekommen sie
ihre prämie auch nicht zurück wenn sie
kein shorten hatten für das ja ist es
richtig oder rechtens dass die
reiserücktrittsversicherung in der
behalten wurde
wenn nicht was habe ich noch für
möglichkeiten um doch noch an mein geld
zu kommen
ja absolut eine berechtigte frage von
frau schubert tatsächlich meine reise
abgesagt worden aber ich habe vorher
noch eine reiserücktrittsversicherung
gebucht wie verhält es sich damit also
das ist tatsächlich eine häufige frage
denn wir haben solche
reiserücktrittversicherung steht wird ja
vielfach abgeschlossen gerade zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt übrigens auch sehr
sinnvoll
ich mache das auch immer läuft oftmals
auch über die kreditkarte beispielsweise
das ist eine versicherung und wenn die
nicht in anspruch genommen wird dann ist
das im grunde genommen für den kunden
gut leider wenn die reise abgesagt wird
gibt es keine rückerstattung weil das
ein folgeschaden ist das hängt ja nicht
unmittelbar zusammen mit der buchung das
macht man zwar wegen der buchung gehört
aber nicht zum buchungs umfang das ist
eine zusatzleistung
und wenn wir jetzt ein verschulden des
veranstalters hätten dann könnten wir
uns über einen schadenersatzanspruch die
prämie zurück pokere holen das wäre
beispielsweise der fall wenn schon
völlig klar war dass die reise nicht
stattfindet und wird die wir trotzdem
noch angeboten und später abgesagt dann
haben wir ein verschulden des
veranstalters dann gibt es auch diese
versicherungsprämie zurück in den
normalen fällen wo quasi der
veranstalter natürlich auch nichts dafür
kann für die absage
corona bedingt dann bekomme ich die
prämie nicht zurück weil es eben ein
folgeschaden ist und da ist mein tipp
tatsächlich schauen sie mal ob sie nicht
vielleicht eine kreditkarte haben wo das
mit inkludiert ist weil solche
versicherungen sind auch sehr teuer und
sie bringen auch wirklich nur dann was
dann wirklich plötzlich erkrankt ist
also das heißt wenn sich eine erkrankung
andeutet weil man da vielleicht schon
hatte dann ist es relativ kompliziert da
geld zu bekommen